chers collègues chers collègues
nous allons commencer
à Johnson
notre première audition car nous avons
une matinée chargée
comme nous aurons une semaine chargée en
séance
donc nous entendons à présent Monsieur
Thomas fantôme directeur général de la
Caisse nationale de l'assurance maladie
la CNAM sur le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat est disponible en vidéo à la
demande
principal bénéficiaire des mesures en
recette le solde de la branche maladie
reste dégradée sans que se dessine à ce
stade les mesures du redressement
radical que dessine pourtant la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années à venir la branche reste
l'un des enjeux majeurs pour les comptes
sociaux je remercie par avance les
intervenants pour la concision de leurs
propos nous disposons d'une heure trente
avant de passer à la suite de notre
ordre du jour et je passe tout de suite
la parole Monsieur le Directeur
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente je
vais donc faire un propos liminaire moi
aussi relativement resserré vous l'avez
vous l'avez évoqué
j'ai pas de financement de la sécurité
sociale présente évidemment une
trajectoire financière de notamment de
l'assurance maladie et donc une
prévision difficile pour 2023 peut-être
saluer même si évidemment ce déficit
reste
[Musique]
significatif puisque un peu supérieur à
6 milliards d'euros dans les prévisions
du gouvernement néanmoins une très nette
amélioration par rapport
aux déficit historique de l'Assurance
Maladie de 2020 2021 et 2022 sous
l'effet
à la fois d'un ralentissement très fort
évidemment des dépenses covid
prévisionnelles on y reviendra peut-être
et puis de recettes qui sont dynamiques
même si une partie de l'explication de
ce dynamisme des recettes provient de
l'inflation qui soutient évidemment la
masse salariale principale recette de
l'Assurance Maladie
ce
[Musique]
bon résultat en tout cas ce résultat en
est amélioration est également soutenu
par des ou pas un transfert en
provenance de la branche famille puisque
le projet de loi de financement prévoit
l'affectation de 2 milliards d'euros à
la branche maladie au travers de la
prise en charge financière des eigies
maternité post accouchement en précisant
que ça n'est bien qu'une prise en charge
financière donc sans aucune sans aucun
changement sur la fois le la gestion de
ces indemnités maternité et et
évidemment pour les pour les assurer
concernés
peut-être
sur ce propos liminaire je vais me
maintenir à
souligner un certain nombre de mesures
qui me semblent importantes et qui pour
un certain nombre d'entre elles
rejoignent ailleurs soit des
propositions que l'assurance maladie
avait réalisé dans le son rapport chargé
produit du mois de juillet soit
différentes initiatives qu'elle avait pu
prendre là aussi c'est dernières années
d'abord commencer par la prévention pour
souligner l'importance d'un certain
nombre de mesures portées par ce projet
de loi
extension des compétences vaccinales
d'un certain nombre de professions et là
dans la continuité de ce qui a été fait
pendant le covid et ce que l'assurance
maladie a signé avec les pharmaciens au
début de l'année avec les infirmiers au
mois de au mois de juillet
généralisation de ce que nous appelons
dans notre jargon pardon de le dire
comme ça au labo sans ordo c'est à dire
la simplification de dépistage de
biologie pour certaines infections
et puis évidemment une mesure clé de ce
PLFSS
la mise en place des rendez-vous de
prévention aux âges clés de la vie
mesure dans laquelle évidemment
l'assurance maladie sera impliquée pour
contribuer à au succès de ces bilans de
prévention et en tout cas mobiliser
le réseau ces systèmes d'information
pour expliquer informer accompagné aller
vers les populations éligibles assez
bilan de prévention deuxième paquet si
j'ose dire qui me semble là aussi
important
différentes mesures qui ont très à
l'accès aux soins dans un contexte
évidemment marqué par des tensions sur
les ressources du système de santé en
termes de ressources humaines et à la
veille si j'ose dire du lancement de la
négociation conventionnelle entre les
médecins et l'assurance maladie évoquer
on y reviendra sans doute la rénovation
de la vie conventionnelle portée par
l'article 22 le dispositif de quatrième
année de médecine générale que le Sénat
connais bien les dispositifs de
simplification
des aides à l'installation qui est
également porté par ce texte en tous les
cas
s'agissant de la rénovation de la vie
conventionnelle la simplification
notamment des modes de négociation des
accords pluriprofessionnels c'est un peu
ça semble un peu secondaire mais en
réalité c'est assez déterminant si nous
voulons continuer accélérer à
l'accompagnement de ces structures
d'exercices coordonnées maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire communauté
professionnelle territoriale de santé
équipe de soins
et donc cet article 22 devrait nous y
aider
troisième troisième volet en tous les
cas si on essaye de prendre les
principaux les principales mesures ce
PLFSS
reprend un certain nombre de
propositions du rapport chargé produit
autour de la de l'encadrement de la
téléconsultation qui
là aussi pour le coup rejoint
directement deux propositions que nous
avions fait dans charger produits de
juillet d'une part donner un statut aux
offreurs de téléconsultation et
notamment ceux qui emploient directement
des professions notamment médicales qui
aujourd'hui se sont construits autour de
centre de santé et
dans un dans un environnement qui n'est
pas complètement satisfaisant pour
encadrer cette activité donc ça nous
semble
utile qui est un cahier des charges qui
maintenant se construisent autour de
cette activité d'offre de télémédecine
et puis une mesure autour de
l'encadrement de la prescription de
l'arrêt de travail pour
supprimer le remboursement de ces
prescriptions d'arrêt de travail en
téléconsultation lorsque le médecin
prescripteur n'est pas le médecin
traitant
voilà sur ce troisième volet quatrième
volet et évidemment le projet de loi de
financement porte un certain nombre de
mesures d'économies ou de régulation
tarifaire là aussi
en lien avec des propositions que
l'assurance maladie a fait en fait à
l'été pardon d'une partition du secteur
de la biologie où nous avions identifié
au delà même de la très forte
augmentation du chiffre d'affaires de la
biologie médicale yokovie de une très
forte augmentation de la rentabilité de
ce secteur à la faveur de la
concentration qu'il a vécu chez les dix
dernières années et ce qui a justifié de
notre côté des propositions d'ajustement
tarifaire que le gouvernement a repris
dans ce projet de loi de financement
avec un objectif d'économie de 250
millions d'euros en 2023 et puis une
mesure
plus de transparence sur les forfaits
techniques de radiologie qui devrait
aussi quelque part permettre avec la
profession je lis d'ailleurs fortement
c'est la même chose pour les biologistes
puisque nous avons engagé cette semaine
officiellement les négociations
tarifaires de discuter également avec
les radiologues sur le contenu des
forfaits techniques le bon usage des
produits de contraste de mettre dans
lequel nous pouvons sans doute améliorer
l'efficience du système
dernier volet madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs et sénateurs et
sénatrice de ce projet de loi qui je
crois concerne l'assurance maladie
les mesures liées à la lutte contre la
fraude sujet sur lequel nous avions
échangé je crois il y a quelques mois
[Musique]
à différents types de fraudes qui par
ailleurs se transforment notamment à la
faveur des innovations numériques et la
diffusion des réseaux sociaux
je terminerai simplement en disant
évidemment cette ce projet de loi
comporte également un certain nombre de
mesures relatives aux produits de santé
et notamment à la fixation des prix dans
un contexte où vous l'avez je pense
également noté le gouvernement à d'ores
et déjà annoncé et même déposer des
amendements pour faire évoluer le texte
déposé à l'Assemblée donc ce sujet
devrait faire l'objet de sans doute de
pas mal d'adaptations dans le cadre du
débat parlementaire à l'Assemblée et au
Sénat en soulignant auprès de vous y
compris les chiffres extrêmement
dynamiques de dépenses de médicaments et
produits de santé en 2021 et en 2022
surtout puisque nous sommes à des
niveaux de dépenses qui étaient sur les
premiers mois 2022 supérieur à 7% sur
les médicaments remboursés sur la ville
ce qui évidemment justifie que l'on se
penche sur
le mécanisme renforcé des régulations
qui évidemment
doivent et peuvent être compatibles avec
des en jeu d'investissement et d'accès à
l'innovation dans notre pays
voilà peut-être madame la Présidente ce
que je voulais partager dans ce propos
liminaire je termine pardon j'ai oublié
juste un élément qui est important
en tout cas aux yeux de l'assurance
maladie le gouvernement a
porté également une mesure de
simplification et d'amélioration de la
couverture des arrêts de travail en
matière de maternité entre voyant une
obligation de subrogation par
l'employeur pour le risque maternité
pour les notamment en commençant par les
par les grandes entreprises et ça nous
semble être de nature à améliorer la
protection des femmes et des foyers
concernés sans que ne soit d'ailleurs
mis en cause la qualité de service rendu
par l'assurance maladie c'est largement
le process de remontée d'information
nécessaire à la liquidation des arrêts
de travail qui justifient ce mécanisme
de subrogation que d'ailleurs les
entreprises connaissent bien puisque un
grand nombre d'entre eux d'entre elles
pardon la pratique donc je ne voulais
pas oublier également cette mesure
mais je m'en tiens là pour ce propos
liminaire merci Monsieur le Directeur je
vais passer la parole à Corinne Imbert
qui rapporte la branche qu'on a dit puis
ensuite Elisabeth Doisneau rapporteur
général
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le directeur pour vos
introductifs j'ai plusieurs questions si
vous le permettez tout d'abord
concernant la soutenabilité financière
de l'assurance maladie l'an dernier vous
considériez vous-même que 10 ans de
déficits importants s'annonçait pour la
branche moins d'un an plus tard et sans
que les besoins de santé naissés et
alors que nous faisons face à un
contexte inflationniste la trajectoire
c'est nettement amélioré donc
permettez-moi d'être tout de même un
petit peu sceptique et est-ce qu'il faut
dès aujourd'hui anticiper des coupes
dans les dépenses et si oui lesquelles
alors que l'on sait que les difficultés
à réguler on connaît les difficultés à
réguler les dépenses de longues dames
faut-il y voir l'annonce de nouveaux
transferts de ressources à la cohérence
un peu douteuse comme le remboursement
par la CNAV de la branche de la prise en
charge du congé maternité postonatale
un nom d'âme en progression de 2,6% à
l'horizon 2027 cette trajectoire qui
s'oppose une ambitieuse modération dans
la dynamique des dépenses vous
paraît-elle réellement tenable et
crédible
ce directeur l'article 22 du PLFSS
prévoit de rénover les conditions des
négociations conventionnelles
il prévoit la possibilité d'un
conventionnement sélectif
le conventionnement sélectif est-il
selon vous un outil pertinent pour
lutter contre les difficultés d'accès
aux soins les conventions
professionnelles sont-elles le bon
véhicule pour ce type de mesure
toujours sur ce sujet et alors que les
négociations d'une nouvelle convention
médicale doivent aboutir au début de
l'année prochaine la Cour des comptes
recommande d'augmenter la part des
versements forfaitaire dans la
rémunération des médecins libéraux
celle-ci est encore pour l'essentiel
bien sûr fondé sur le paiement à l'acte
l'augmentation des rémunérations
forfait-elle est-elle pertinente à votre
sens et selon qu'elle proportion ce
sujet sera-t-il poussé par une cam lors
des négociations à venir
concernant le médicament qui est l'un
des principaux piliers des économies
attendues pour pour lame le PLFSS porte
un nouveau mécanisme de financement des
thérapies innovantes prévoit que
l'assurance maladie assure en lieu et
place des hôpitaux la gestion des flux
financiers vers l'industriel et procède
un paiement à plusieurs échéances
conditionnés à des résultats cliniques
en vie réelle ce dispositif vous
paraît-il opérationnel l'étude d'impact
du gouvernement estime que le dispositif
pourrait permettre d'économiser 100
millions d'euros de 2024 ce chiffrage
vous paraît-il réaliste
le pfss prévoit un recueil annuel
d'informations relatives au charges
associées aux équipements matériels
lourds d'imagerie médicale pouvez-vous
nous préciser les éléments à votre
disposition suggérant que les tarifs des
forfaits techniques sont surévalués au
regard des courriels l'actualisation des
forces et techniques sera-t-elle faite
sur le seul fondement des données
récoltées je vous remercie
peut-être et puis ensuite je vous
laisserai répondre avant qu'on passe au
elisabethon oui merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le directeur
pour ses propos liminaires j'aurais
juste une question de la part de
Jean-Marie vallorenberg qui est pris par
les perturbations SNCF ce matin
concernant les fraudes c'est des
questions qui qui reviennent
systématiquement parce qu'il est très
attentif au progrès que qui peuvent être
faits en réalité vous avez annoncé il y
a quelques semaines voire même quelques
mois que vous alliez redoubler d'efforts
pour faire la chasse aux fraudeur
vous avez aussi annoncé des chiffres
pour 2024 qui serait de l'ordre de 500
millions d'euros de préjudice par an je
pense que vous avez effectivement revu
vos priorités depuis la crise covid qui
vous a empêché en quelque sorte d'aller
à cette chasse aux fraudeur puisque vous
agents étaient mobilisés sur d'autres
d'autres travaux est-ce que vous pouvez
comment nous dire parce que vous je
pense que vous misez sur le croisement
des données avec un certain nombre
d'administrations est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner quelques éléments sur
justement ces nouvelles capacités que
vous envisagez et quels sont les
chiffres réels des fraudes et sur quel
finalement fraude il faut agir le plus
vite possible et le mieux possible merci
Monsieur le Directeur très bien je vous
laisse répondre et ensuite on passera
aux collègues
merci beaucoup par rapport aux questions
posées par Madame la Scénic
il est vrai que le déficit
2023 se réduit nettement plus rapidement
que les précédentes projections plus
annuelle du gouvernement pouvait le
laisser penser pour pour je crois trois
raisons la première c'est
en réalité la dynamique des recettes
puisque
en 2022 comme en 2023 nous sommes sur
des dynamiques de masse salariale
supérieure à 5% donc extrêmement
favorable alors derrière cette dynamique
il y a une entre guillemets une nouvelle
évidemment moins favorable qui est celle
que cette ce dynamisme est lié notamment
à l'inflation même si sur 2022 il y a
encore pas mal de création d'emplois
également donc ça c'est le la première
raison la deuxième raison c'est ça me
permet d'ailleurs de répondre à la
deuxième question le
commencer par le gouvernement de
d'opérer un transfert financier de la
branche famille vers la Manche maladie à
hauteur de 2 milliards d'euros qui de
fait contribuent à accélérer le
redressement de la branche maladie je
en tant que directeur général j'ai
évidemment pas à me positionner mais si
on met la retraite peut-être sans doute
à part le fait que le gouvernement est
une approche transversale des finances
sociales et des différentes
des différents équilibres entre les
différentes branches me semble quelque
chose de de logique et de cohérent et
d'ailleurs relativement continue depuis
une vingtaine d'années et
mais évidemment c'est une responsabilité
qui lui incombe le troisième la
troisième raison
et d'ailleurs comme pour les recettes
une raison teintée d'incertitude
également c'est
la baisse significative des dépenses qui
sera liées au covid en 2023 vous le
savez le gouvernement a prévu une
enveloppe prévisionnelle à la hauteur
d'un milliard d'euros sur les dépenses
covid 600 millions sur les vaccins 400
millions sur le test estimation d'un
lui-même indiqué que c'était une
estimation provision estimative qui
évidemment n'est pas une enveloppe
fermée et donc ces trois éléments
justifient explique en effet le
redressement accéléré de la branche même
si vous l'avez dit un Président nous
restons tout de même à des difficiles
qui ne sont pas
anecdotiques
s'agissant de long terme plus rien
annuelle il est clair que la trajectoire
poste
2023 est exigeante elle
nécessitera le renforcement des actions
à la fois de de maîtrise médicalisée des
dépenses de gestion du risque déficience
de qualité et de lutte contre la fraude
sujet sur lequel nous avons travaillé
nous continuons à travailler nous
faisons des propositions chaque année
mettons en oeuvre des plans d'action
mais il est certain que c'est une
trajectoire exigeante
s'agissant de l'article 22 sur lequel
vous m'interrogez
alors peut-être bien préciser en tout
cas tel que nous lisons l'article
s'agissant notamment des mesures
démographiques
l'intérêt de cet article 22 c'est qu'il
crée une base transversale pour
l'ensemble des professions de santé
permettant en partenaires conventionnel
en effet d'agir sur la démographie en
fonction de différents critères
à la fois de formation d'expérience
professionnelle alors que aujourd'hui
les bases législatives pour agir était
différente selon les conventions selon
les professions de santé ce qui nous
avait d'ailleurs permis de prendre un
certain nombre de mesures s'agissant de
la répartition des notamment des
infirmières libérales et des masters
kinésithérapeutes sur le territoire là
le texte pose un principe et je crois un
principe aussi de responsabilité
vis-à-vis des personnes à
conventionnelles pour qu'il puisse se
saisir pour toutes les professions de ce
sujet de répartition sur les territoires
et elle lui donne potentiellement des
leviers importants
je pense qu'il est important de quand on
aborde ces sujets de bien mesurer les
différences fondamentales qu'il y a
aujourd'hui entre les différentes
professions de santé sur ces sujets
autant nous avons notamment s'agissant
des infirmiers libéraux et des masseurs
kinésithérapeutes une dynamique
démographique extrêmement significative
extrêmement forte depuis 10 ans
nous avons 100% de plus d'infirmières
libérales dans le pays depuis 20 ans 50%
de masseurs qui naît de plus depuis 10
ans et donc avant tout un problème de
répartition sur les territoires
mais une offre qui est quand même
relativement abondante je ne dis pas
qu'elle est satisfaisante sur tous les
territoires mais elle est globalement
significative ça n'est pas la même chose
pour les médecins
puisque globalement sur les dix
dernières années la densité médicale a
diminué que ce soit sur les généralistes
sur les spécialistes et qu'on est face à
des situations de tension à peu près sur
tous les territoires
[Musique]
comment ça produire des effets même
s'ils s'en doute ils sont insuffisants
vous m'interrogez sur les rémunérations
forfaitaires
alors d'abord elles ont elles ont tout
de même sur les 15 dernières années
significativement progressé jusqu'à
représenter notamment pour les médecins
généralistes entre 10 et 15% de leur de
leur rémunération ce qui alors que
c'était quelques pourcents encore à la
fin des années 2000
nous considérons qu'il est nécessaire de
continuer cette ce mouvement tout en
partageant avec vous pardon de le faire
de façon un peu basique une évidence qui
est que
le double mouvement de
d'augmentation de la valeur des actes
dans un contexte inflationniste qui va
se poser et d'une volonté que nous
portons de faire grandir le poids des
forfaits dans la rémunération finit par
mettre une tension sur l'enveloppe
financière globale qu'il faut ensuite
savoir mesurer maîtriser et donc ce sera
sûrement
des éléments
compliqués de la discussion mais en tous
les cas l'investissement en assurance
maladie dans le forfait médecin traitant
dans la rémunération qui lie
des objectifs de santé publique de
prévention de qualité
à l'activité des médecins ça nous semble
être une voix qu'il faut continuer à
approfondir
s'agissant du
médicament
vous l'avez vous avez évoqué la mesure
qui en effet fait évoluer le mode de
rémunération sur des médicaments très
innovants
nous faisons face depuis maintenant
plusieurs années à une
augmentation extrêmement significative
des coûts de traitement
unitaire et des demandes des
laboratoires sur des médicaments sur des
populations ciblées mais à des niveaux
de de tarifs individuels qui dépasse
souvent plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'euros voire au-delà et de ce point de
vue là la mesure proposée par le
gouvernement y compris de de de paiement
à échéance différé nous semble être
intéressantes et participer de une
maîtrise de ses coûts qui est
indispensable à la soutenabilité du
voilà des dépenses de produits de santé
dans un cadre qui a fait l'objet
annuel vis-à-vis des industriels
je pense que je pense que j'ai oublié
pardon votre toute dernière question
alors nous avons fait il y a 4 ans des
travaux mais en chambre justement pour
essayer d'estimer les coûts
liés et le rapport entre les coûts réels
et les
tarifs des forfaits techniques et nous
avions considéré à l'époque l'assurance
maladie avait concerné à l'époque que
ces estimations justifiées des
ajustements tarifaires des des forfaits
techniques mais la réalité c'est que
c'était des estimations en chambre nous
voulons sortir de cette discussion
avec avec les professionnels et ce que
souhaite également le gouvernement pour
voilà essayer de construire une vraie
évaluation basée sur des sur des sur une
étude je dirais en vie réelle permettant
d'estimer plus finement
les différents types de coûts coût fixe
en équipement en locaux ou en personnel
coup en termes de consommables pour
voilà avoir un débat plus
[Musique]
étayés par des données de meilleure
qualité que des estimations encore une
fois en chambre je précise également que
[Musique]
cette mesure est retient l'attention
entre guillemets parce qu'elle est de
nature législative je pense qu'il faut
être attentif à construire cette ce
travail d'estimation avec la profession
l'assurance maladie ne souhaite pas
mener ces travaux de manière annuler
latérale et à la fois le choix de
l'échantillon la méthode etc tout ça
doit être travaillé avec la profession
et puis partagez avec vous que nous
travaillons justement avec la profession
sur une mesure autour du bon usage pour
le coup des produits de contraste
aujourd'hui on dépense entre deux à
quatre fois plus d'argent pour les
produits de contraste que dans les
autres pays européens parce que nos prix
sont plus élevés et parce que nos
volumes sont massivement plus élevés que
c'est nos voisins et je ne suis pas
alors que je ne crois pas
fondamentalement que nos voisins
européens est un recours à aux examens
de radiologie nettement inférieur aux
autres en tout cas sur honnêtement moins
bien pris en charge que nous sur ce
volet donc c'est un sujet que nous avons
travaillé compris d'ailleurs en très
bonne intelligence avec les
professionnels sur lequel nous espérons
déboucher dans les prochaines semaines
madame douanou vous m'interrogez sur sur
la fraude
comme vous le comme vous l'évoquez nous
sommes fixés un objectif de résultat à
l'horizon 2024 de d'identifier et de
stopper 500 millions d'euros
de en lien avec la lutte contre la
fraude donc en effet ce sont nos
objectifs qui sont de fait
ambitieux puisque le le rendement
historique de nos actions avant Chris
sanitaire était de 290 millions d'euros
donc c'est un effort important que nous
entendons faire il se base sur des
travaux d'évaluation que nous avons
engagé nous avions partagé des premiers
résultats avec la Commission au
printemps sur les infirmiers et sur la
C2S nous avons poursuivi ces travaux
d'évaluation sur les médecins
généralistes et sur les transporteurs
sanitaires
qui s'additionne ces deux professions
fixent des des fourchettes de fraude
entre 2 et 5% et nous allons continuer
c'est travaux d'évaluation pour faire
sujet par sujet brique par brique
puisque comme je n'avais plus je crois
le partager avec vous nous considérons
que la fraude à l'assurance maladie se
sont en réalité défauts dans différents
domaines donc de ce point de vue là nous
avons donc présenté une stratégie et
mieux évaluée la fraude mieux prévenir
sa mise en oeuvre mieux détecter et
contrôler et sanctionner plus rapidement
plus efficacement le partage
d'informations avec à la fois des autres
branches et des
outils d'automatisation des données de
fiabilisation des données à la source le
développement de l'ordonnance numérique
tous ces tous ces échanges de données
vont nous permettre sont des leviers au
service de cette stratégie que nous
allons
évidemment que nous avons commencé à
déployer puisqu'on ne parle pas d'une
page blanche mais que nous allons
accélérer dans les prochaines semaines
et les prochains mois
Monsieur le Directeur alors nous avons
collègues inscrits on va prendre une
première salle de
Philippe mouillé Daniel Chassin Bernard
Chaumier Christine bonfantier Olivier
Hainaut et Laurence Rossignol Philippe
mouillé merci madame le Président ce
lecteur d'abord merci pour pour
présentation je suis aussi clair moi je
vais focaliser sur plutôt le vélo le
volet médico-social étant rapporteur de
reporter du domaine
donc j'aurais voulu avoir votre votre
avis concernant les calendriers
notamment sur la réforme attendue les
concernant les autres techniques à la
fois concernant les fauteuils roulants
donc là on attend un certain nombre de
d'informations méthode décret
réforme des techniques et on pensait
éventuellement avoir une liste avec une
nouvelle nomenclature à travers le
budget rien n'est inscrit de l'évolution
où ça en tout cas ça ne transparaît pas
voilà donc je voulais avoir votre regard
sur cette évolution qui a été annoncée
et et attendu voilà donc ça ça concerne
les autres techniques deuxième point ça
concerne les votes qui ont eu lieu à
l'Assemblée nationale concernant
l'encadrement de la téléconsultation et
notamment de téléconsultation à domicile
qu'on peut comprendre qu'il y a un
certain nombre de questionnements qui
qui se soit posé sur la pratique je vais
avoir votre sentiment vis-à-vis
notamment d'un public qui ne peut pas
aujourd'hui se déplacer de par les
problématiques de santé ou de handicap
et puis dernière question ça concerne la
lutte contre la fraude vous avez donc
annoncé des mesures complémentaires des
des objectifs attendus nous avons
beaucoup débattues ici au printemps de
la carte Vitale biométrique avec avec
une ligne budgétaire qui a été créée
avec 20 millions d'euros aujourd'hui
dans les nouvelles nomenclatures ou
qu'on se regarde le PDF c'est le ligne a
disparu non elle existe toujours avec le
montant de zéro voilà donc est-ce que
aujourd'hui vous faites partie ceux qui
ont dans les débats poussés à ce que la
ligne soit ramenée à zéro ou est-ce que
vous considez vous avez une autre
solution plus adaptée pour répondre à la
problématique voilà en sachant que c'est
votre réponse sera très attendu au Sénat
merci
madame la Présidente donc moi trois
questions si vous voulez on a voté hier
à la quatrième année
de professionnalisation de l'internat
alors bien sûr c'est pas pour 2023 mais
il faudrait annoncer aux étudiants
combien la sécurité sociale pense qu'il
faut donner aux internes puisqu'il n'est
pas question de leur payer après 10 ans
d'études de 2000 euros par mois
ensuite une question sur la sur la
pharmacie donc vous avez renoncé à
référencer des médicaments par appel
d'offres qui serait venu d'un ou de
Chine et donc ça aurait été très
péjoratif pour les pharmacies d'après
mes informations et aussi sûrement
manquer de médicaments et aussi vous
avez diminué la
le l'achat de médicaments de 1 million
plus de milliers plus de milliards et
est-ce que ça va pas entraîner des
problèmes au niveau de la recherche
puisque les médicaments baissent depuis
environ 10 ans et enfin au niveau de la
pharmacie est-ce que les pharmaciens
vont pouvoir les clients enfin les
patients vont pouvoir être remboursés si
par exemple ils veulent sevrer du tabac
mais uniquement en allant à la pharmacie
ou si des médicaments qui normalement
devraient être de vrai pouvoir être
délivré par la pharmacie par exemple
comme le monury pour les cystites mais
ne sera pas remboursé s'il y a pas de
médecin et enfin c'est la même chose
aussi pour des lorsque les pharmacies
délivrent des médicaments pour la
déshydratation des nourrissons le samedi
après-midi alors qu'il y a plus de
médecins mais les gens ne peuvent pas
être remboursés merci
merci Madame à présente merci Monsieur
le Directeur général trois questions si
je m'en tenir à trois questions la
première Monsieur le Directeur Général
notre pays vit une période d'inflation
l'inflation c'est un chiffre moyen mais
on sait que suivant la structure de la
dépense on impacte est très différent
par exemple les catégories populaires
sont exposées en fait plus fortement à
l'inflation que ceux qui ont un reste à
vivre plus importants des données de la
connaissance que vous avez des
établissements de santé est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si vous si les
établissements de santé en particulier
les hôpitaux sont a priori exposés au
taux d'inflation moyen de notre pays ou
sont plus exposés ou sont moins exposés
à l'inflation c'est ma première question
ma deuxième question c'est que en
présentant le budget de la Sécurité
sociale et son
sa perspective d'évolution les ministres
concernés nous ont indiqué vouloir se
réinscrire dans la trajectoire 2010 2018
c'est une trajectoire qui a été marquée
par un redressement des comptes
uniquement axé sur par une politique de
l'offre et pourtant en l'occurrence sur
les dépenses or il y a dans le même
temps un discours et des mêmes
d'ailleurs
nous la complexité sur la nécessité de
passer d'une logique d'offre plus à une
logique de réponse aux besoins de santé
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire comment vous voyez qu'elles
indicateurs vous voyez cette mutation
vers les besoins de santé dans ce projet
de PLFSS puis ma troisième et dernière
question porte sur
une branche qui est pas strictement la
vôtre mais enfin une forte interaction
la branche ATMP
la branche ATMP chroniquement en
excédent or se multiplie les rapports
rapport au Sénat par rapport à
l'assemblée rapport d'experts sur
nécessité d'avoir une politique de santé
au travail beaucoup plus affirmé
la Cour des comptes d'ailleurs vient
encore de pointer les risques dans les
établissements médico-sociaux
comment expliquer vous enfin comment
portez-vous vous l'assurance maladie
une sortie de ce paradoxe c'est-à-dire
de cesser d'utiliser uniquement les
excédents de la branche ATMP pour
combler les déficits de la branche
maladie je vous remercie
Christine bonfantie dossard et puis
après je vous laisserai répondre oui
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur ma question fait écho à celle
d'Elisabeth Doisneau sur la fraude à
laquelle vous avez déjà répondu
toutefois
l'article 44 permet donc au directeur de
CPAM de demander en cas d'erreur
d'erreur de facturation ou de fraude
identifier le remboursement non plus
uniquement des indus correspondants au
sel au seul factures contrôlées mais des
indus globaux qu'ils calculent un
extrapolant sur le résultat des factures
à l'ensemble des factures émises par les
professionnels est-ce à dire que
l'erreur et la fraude seront traités de
la même manière
je vous laisse répondre Monsieur le
Directeur parce que la liste c'est
allongée après ça va faire beaucoup
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
l'assurance maladie est parti prenante
de travaux sur les aides techniques même
si elle n'en est pas complètement leader
ce qui est logique puisque notamment les
équipes du ministère
notamment nous ce qui des choses qui
avancent mais qui ne sont pas
complètement simples vous le vous le
savez c'est les travaux autour des des
fauteuils roulants
qui ont fait l'objet de pas mal de
travaux avant l'été pas mal de
discussions avec les acteurs à la fois
les associations et les industriels et
des prestataires des discussions se
poursuivent sur ce sur cette thématique
évidemment nous y sommes attentifs à la
fois sur
des logiques de de régulation et de
meilleurs accès à ces aides techniques
comme le rapport les différents rapports
sur ce sujet
proposer sur
sur la télé consultation à domicile et
les alors commenter des amendements
déposés en commission des affaires
sociales de l'Assemblée
peut-être simplement dire deux choses
d'une part
l'assurance maladie n'est ni de près ni
de loin
comment dirais-je à l'origine de ces
propositions
et
alors même que nous pensons qu'il faut
comme je l'ai dit trouver une place
mieux encadrée à la téléconsultation
cette proposition serait quand même
extrêmement restrictive et donc ça ça
n'est pas en lien avec des choses que
nous avons auxquelles nous avons pu
réfléchir
la seule chose néanmoins que je porte
c'est que
pour le coup la téléconstitution
assistée notamment à domicile peut-être
un plus mais je le positionne comme un
plus et nous avons notamment des
expérimentations des travaux de visite à
domicile d'infirmières qui font une
téléconstration assistée avec le médecin
traitant et nous savons que même s'il
faut soutenir les visites à domicile des
médecins notamment des médecins
traitants leur capacité à faire beaucoup
de visites de fêtes et limiter donc
promouvoir une pratique comme celle-là
mais promouvoir
nous semble être intéressant mais soyons
attentifs à sans doute encore une fois
trouver une place plus stable de la
téléconsultation dans notre paysage mais
de pas non plus aboutir à à la brider
excessivement ça n'est pas en tout cas
notre proposition
s'agit sur la carte Vitale biométrique
sujet important alors
comment dire d'une part l'assurance
maladie n'avait pas sollicité de crédit
du côté de l'État et n'a pas non plus
demandé que ces crédits lui soit retiré
donc je je dirais je me tiens en dehors
de cette affaire
même si évidemment nous sommes
concernés et là dessus deux points nous
travaillons un
une un dématérialiser la dématérialiser
pardon la carte vitale à permettre je
dis bien permettre à nous assurer qu'il
le souhaiteront de pouvoir mettre leur
carte Vitale sur leur smartphone
et ça c'est un service que nous allons
lancer dans les dans les prochaines
semaines nous sommes en train encore de
le tester nous la montée c'est dans
différents départements nous sommes
encore à un niveau de qualité du
parcours
usagé par non de rentrer dans les
détails qui est encore insuffisante pour
pouvoir le proposer plus largement mais
c'est voilà c'est quelque chose que nous
mon nom c'est à la fois de la
simplification et aussi
je pense une meilleure une mesure de
sécurisation et de bon usages de la
carte vitale et de et de lutte contre la
fraude au-delà de ça et alors cette
pardon cette dématérialisation elle
intègre
une part de biométrie dans ce qu'on
appelle l'enroulement puisque pour
pouvoir faire le process de mettre votre
carte Vitale sur votre smartphone il
faut adresser à l'assurance maladie il
faudra demain adresser à l'Assurance
Maladie votre pièce d'identité et une
captation biométrique voilà donc dans le
roulement
c'est volontaire c'est volontaire
nous pensons que beaucoup de nos assurés
usagers y compris des personnes âgées si
nous demain matin nous disions que la
carte Vitale n'existe plus en physique
je pense qu'on aura un sérieux problème
d'acceptabilité dans notre pays sur une
carte vitale qui est quand même dans le
quotidien des Français
s'agissant de la carte Vitale
biométrique qui irait même peut-être je
ne sais pas au-delà de l'intégration de
la biométrie dans le rendement le
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
à annoncé la le lancement d'une mission
de l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales pour
voilà instruire ce sujet et nous nous
tenons évidemment à la disposition de
des inspecteurs pour approfondir ce
sujet
vous m'avez interrogé sur le
coup de la quatrième pardon alors d'une
part vous le savez le ministre a aussi
les ministres avec la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
à lancer une mission de de concertation
et qui va aborder l'ensemble je crois
des paramètres de cette quatrième année
le calendrier le contenu le mode
d'exercice et la rémunération et je suis
intimement convaincu que il nous faudra
trouver des rémunérations attractives
pour réussir la cette quatrième année en
tout cas l'assurance m'a dit y est prête
elle est prête à cet investissement elle
est prête à ce que cette cette quatrième
année qui est à la fois une dernière
année de formation finalement il y a une
première année d'exercice encadré en
tout cas c'est comme ça que que nous la
voyons
l'assurance maladie considère que c'est
un un investissement très important et
que il faut y mettre les moyens pour
dire les choses et donc nous participons
évidemment aux travaux de
de la mission qui a été lancée par les
ministres et qui je crois doit déboucher
d'ici la fin de l'année et dans cet état
d'esprit de pouvoir proposer aux
internes concernés une rémunération
attractive après tout ça doit se
construire avec la avec la mission
s'agissant de s'agissant des
inquiétudes
notamment exprimées par les pharmaciens
sur
les mécanismes de de référencement
je comment dirais le gouvernement adore
c'est déjà annoncé que il ne mettrait
pas en oeuvre ce référencement et qu'il
proposait que des travaux
complémentaires se mettent en place pour
pouvoir évaluer la pertinence d'un tel
dispositif
si j'étais un tout petit peu
comment dirais-je non pas provocateur
mais mais j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
à nos amis pharmaciens et même si cette
mesure ne fait pas partie des
propositions de l'assurance maladie
la puissance publique achète
mettre en place des procédures d'achat
c'est quelque chose que les pharmaciens
dégrossissent connaissent donc a priori
après tout ça n'a rien d'absolument
extraordinaire mais
là dessus sans doute qu'il est
nécessaire d'approfondir les travaux
préparatoires et la discussion donc en
tout cas c'est le chemin qui a choisi le
gouvernement
s'agissant des du CE brass tabagique
vous l'avez évoqué nous nous assurance
maladie rembourse aujourd'hui sur
ordonnance c'est
ces produits
on en reste là dans le cadre actuel je
ne sais pas peut-être que les choses
évolueront mais pour le moment on en est
là
il s'agissant du milliard d'économies
sur les le prix du médicament je l'ai
évoqué
ce montant important doit aussi être
relié à la dynamique dynamisme des des
dépenses de médicaments que nous
observons
depuis notamment sur l'année 2022
monsieur sénateur geomier vous
m'interrogez sur finalement est-ce que
les hôpitaux sont plus ou moins exposés
à l'inflation alors je le dis
franchement nous n'avons pas mené
d'études approfondie qui permettrait de
situer le curseur
[Musique]
la régulation hospitalière et la
fixation des budgets étant vous le savez
du ressort du ministère
de la santé des agences régionales de
santé après vous savez vous le savez
évidemment bien
de fait contenu de la structure de coût
d'un hôpital qui est à la fois notamment
lié à en grande parade d'amas salariale
et ensuite un certain nombre de coups
liés notamment à de l'énergie ou à des
achats qui peuvent être directement
impactés par l'inflation clairement la
structure de coût porte un impact
important dès lors que l'inflation
augmente c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement a à la fois annoncé des
enveloppes complémentaires sur 2022 et
proposer un nom d'âme 2023
nettement plus élevé que les gendarmes
d'avant
d'aventrise mais voilà après pour
évaluer est-ce que c'est une du coup
est-ce qu'ils sont plus impactés ou pas
ce ne sont pas des travaux que a pu
mener en tout cas dans le dans le passé
dans un passé récent s'agissant de alors
poser une question difficile sur
est-ce qu'on est capable de passer de
d'une stratégie quelque part de l'offre
à une réponse aux besoins
je serai j'aurais envie de pardon pas de
m'échapper mais en tous les cas de
répondre à directement à votre question
que en tout cas notre objectif c'est de
c'est de garantir ou de faire que les
ressources de l'Assurance Maladie soient
bien utiliser pour répondre le mieux
possible aux besoins pourquoi je me
permets de le dire comme ça je crois que
la quête de l'évaluation des besoins et
de s'assurer que les ressources sont
suffisantes pour répondre aux besoins
est une quête délicate
l'estimation des besoins et il y a
sûrement tendance à à monter assez
fortement vers l'infini si je caricature
volontiers la discussion et c'est une
vraie discussion de fond je crois aussi
que derrière ses besoins il y a un mode
de recours
et que si j'ai besoin
d'un soin
à 24 et 48 heures alors mon premier
réflexe ça doit être d'appeler mon
médecin traitant doux et la nécessité
pour l'assurance aussi des redonner du
temps médical disponible pour les
médecins traitants pour prendre en
charge des patients mon deuxième réflexe
ça doit être l'appeler le 15 et de
vérifier si derrière il y a un mécanisme
de régulation qui fonctionne et qui
permet de déclencher des soins de
programmés une infection notre boulot à
nous c'est justement d'organiser ce soit
nos programmes et puis dernier si ça
tout ça ne passe pas éventuellement
d'appeler d'aller aux urgences donc
je crois que c'est difficile de de
partir d'une estimation des besoins qui
ne je crois pas que ce soit vous dis
mais en tout cas pour nous ça doit aussi
s'intégrer dans l'organisation des
parcours
la juste mobilisation des ressources de
du système de santé pour le mur pour
répondre le mieux possible aux besoins
et dans ce cadre là nous avons sans
doute des progrès très importants à
faire mais ça veut aussi dire d'ailleurs
mieux détecter les besoins d'ailleurs je
prends un exemple récent nous avons
lancé il y a trois semaines une campagne
sur l'insuffisance cardiaque pourquoi
parce que nous voyons que beaucoup de
d'assurer et beaucoup de patients en
réalité de cette pathologie sans même le
savoir donc finalement il ne verbalisent
même pas ce besoin alors même qu'ils ont
besoin d'être prise en charge le plus
rapidement possible et qu'on sait que
s'ils sont pris en charge rapidement
alors ça sera meilleur pour leur santé
et aussi meilleur pour les dépenses de
l'assurance maladie puisqu'on évitera
une hospitalisation etc après mieux
relier c'est ce que les travaux du
conseil pour l'avenir la science mais
avait dit et je crois que c'est la
logique du CNR porté par le par le
ministre mieux relié nos priorités de
santé publique avec les moyens dédiés je
crois que c'est ce qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de faire davantage encore dans
les prochaines années je crois que c'est
le sens de l'OM porté par par le
gouvernement
s'agissant de des excédents de la
branche ATMP sujet éminemment sensible
puisque vous le vous le savez les
partenaires sociaux ont engagé une
négociation sur
la
sur quelque part la branche sur son
justement son équilibre financier et son
organisation donc je ne prétends pas
faire de commentaires particuliers
peut-être deux éléments si vous me
permettez
là aussi parlons d'être un peu
impertinent mais
l'importance des excédents montre bien
que
ils sont ils ne sont pas préemptés pour
équilibrer la Manche maladie
et puis deuxième élément
mais là c'est aussi la responsabilité du
gouvernement vous le savez il y a une
instance indépendante dirigée par un
magistrat la Cour des comptes sur la
base de travaux scientifiquement
indépendants qui détermine l'évaluation
de la sous-déclaration des accidents du
travail professionnel c'est pas quelque
chose sur lequel le gouvernement et
l'assurance maladie décide d'un trade
plume en disant voilà cette année ça
sera un milliard et demi claque etc
c'est des travaux indépendants et le
gouvernement a choisi de retenir le bas
de la fourchette dans les travaux
d'évaluation donc la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est que on n'est pas dans une
situation où il y aurait une ponction
indu de la branche ATMP pour équilibrer
la branche maladie on est dans une
situation il y a une estimation
indépendante pour lequel le gouvernement
prend le bal à fourchette et pour lequel
il décide quelque part de rembourser
à la branche maladie des dépenses indues
de son côté donc c'est un sujet très
sensible qui ne fait pas consensus mais
j'insiste j'insiste sur quand même mais
j'insiste sur le fait que
l'estimation elle ne sort pas nulle part
et que c'est bien une commission
indépendante et c'est des travaux quand
même très approfondis qui sont menés et
je n'ai pas vu travaux scientifique
sérieux qui démontrait
la fragilité de ces travaux d'évaluation
mais comme tous travaux d'évaluation
scientifique évidemment ça nécessite
d'être challenger tout ça pour dire en
tous les cas que de notre côté notre
responsabilité à nous c'est de comment
dire agit d'assurer la gestion
opérationnelle de la branche dans un
cadre qui est fixé par la Commission des
accidents du travail et la maladie
professionnelle des maladies
professionnelles c'est la responsabilité
des partenaires sociaux et donc nous
nous situons évidemment dans cette
perspective et dans la perspective de la
préparation de la cause en terminant
pardon monsieur sénateur sur le fait que
comment dirais-je le
[Musique]
l'investissement dans la prévention
et dans des dispositifs de soutien aux
différents secteurs qui sont exposés à
des niveaux de sinistre élevés vous avez
évoqué le médico-social évidemment ça
fait partie de nos priorités et on
souhaite aller plus loin sans doute
dédier des moyens supplémentaires assez
politiques et assez levier de prévention
assez contrats de prévention qu'on nous
passions avec les entreprises qui
mobilisent des moyens qu'il faut sans
doute continuer à renforcer
madame la sénatrice vous m'avez
interrogé sur le dispositif
d'échantillonnage
c'est quelque chose que nous
oui c'est quelque chose que nous que
nous souhaitons utiliser de manière
encadrée nous ne traitons pas de la même
façon des erreurs
et les fraudes mais il est vrai
également que dès lors que nous
observons des des indus importants sur
la base d'échantillons qui sont
représentatifs dans des cas bien
encadrés et je le dis également ça ne
concerne pas la tarification
hospitalière ils ne nous semble pas des
raisonnables de pouvoir passer à des
logiques
d'extrapolation mais encore une fois
dans des conditions extrêmement
maîtrisées
merci alors Olivier Hainaut Laurence
Rossignol et Miliane Pomerol l'année le
héros Oliviero oui merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le directeur
pour vos propos comme vous avez déjà
abordé la question des indemnités
journalières en tant que rapporteur de
la branche famille je n'y reviens pas
j'en pense pas moins naturellement
Daniel Chassin a évoqué les questions
liées à la pharmacie donc je n'y reviens
pas non plus je voudrais vous poser
trois questions d'abord revenir sur les
propos de Philippe mouillé sur la carte
Vitale je pense que basculer dans une
carte Vitale nouvelle génération c'est
pas la même chose que des matérialisé
c'est deux choses différentes on a des
on a dans nos poches des cartes
nouvelles génération pour des tas de
choses c'est un moyen pour lutter
efficacement contre la fraude parce
qu'il y a pas que que la fraude des
professionnels naturellement et si on
veut basculer aussi pour sécuriser un
dispositif pour qu'il y ait plus le
doute sur ces questions je crois que
c'est c'est nécessaire et qu'il va
falloir accélérer sur cette question et
se donner une perspective j'allais dire
un horizon non je vais dire une
perspective plutôt monsieur director
alors ça c'est la première observation
qui est aussi une question
revenir sur la question des actes
redondants l'ombre portée de Jean-Marie
vont laurenberg
vit dans cette dans cette commission
même s'il y a des problèmes de train
est-ce que vous avez aussi la des
chiffres à nous donner ou des des
perspectives et puis avoir aussi
quelques quelques chiffres sur le
dossier médical partagé je vous remercie
très bien Laurence Rossignol merci merci
madame la Présidente bonjour Monsieur le
Directeur je suis là
ma question s'adresse au directeur de la
CNAM en tant que directeur du meilleur
centre d'observation des comportements
de prescription à la fois des médecins
et aussi des patients et elle porte sur
une question que je me pose peut-être
vous avez pas la réponse aujourd'hui
mais peut-être je vais vous stimuler et
vous inciter à la chercher
on observe que la consommation des
psychotropes et antidépresseurs à
beaucoup augmenté ces dernières années
en particulier sur la base du covid et
que parallèlement les consultations en
visio ont également beaucoup également
beaucoup augmenté et je m'interroge
parce que mon
interrogation est un peu empirique vous
savez nous on a on a des petits capteurs
dans la société qui sont des capteurs
directs je m'interroge sur une
augmentation des prescriptions
d'antidépresseurs en premier en faire
prescription
dans le cadre des consultations en visio
sans pour autant de nouvelles
consultations ensuite et dans des
conditions qui sont d'un point de vue
thérapeutique un peu border voilà un peu
limite pour être très précise et je
voudrais savoir si vous avez pu examiner
de manière globale
je pense que ma question est
voilà est une bonne question je vous
remercie
non mais de manière globale est-ce qu'on
peut est-ce qu'on a examiné est-ce que
vous avez identifié les modifications de
prescription médicamenteuses liées à
l'augmentation des téléconsultations
voilà
Monsieur le Directeur
oui merci madame la Présidente je me
suis directeur ma question porte sur le
premier point que vous avez évoqué vous
avez dit la première mesure phare c'est
une augmentation de la prévention en
même temps en place trois consultations
qui sont pas des consultations pour moi
de prévisions et de dépistage ce qui est
quand même différent
je voudrais parler de fait que on sait
aujourd'hui que 90% des pathologies
chroniques sont liées à des facteurs
extérieurs on a vu ce printemps le
rapport de notre collègue du groupe
écologiste sur l'importance de
l'exposant mais des facteurs extérieurs
qui représentent 90% des pathologies
chroniques et qu'il faut agir sur ces
facteurs pour faire vraiment de la
prévention puisque aujourd'hui je crois
que c'est 3% à peine du budget de la
Sécu qui est consacré à la prévention et
le reste au curatif on s'est on connaît
tous ces facteurs sur j'allais dire la
malbouffe pour reprendre en termes bien
connu l'alcool de tabac la pollution de
l'air de l'eau je voulais pas vous
parler moi spécifiquement de l'activité
physique adaptée on a vu l'année
dernière une audition de l'Inserm nous
montrant l'intérêt de l'activité
physique adaptée dans beaucoup de
pathologies un chiffre m'avait frappé
c'était celui de 40% de récidive en
moins de cancer du sein pour des femmes
qui faisaient du sport par rapport à
celle qui n'en faisait pas et l'activité
physique adaptée dans le cadre du cancer
du sein n'est pas remboursé est-ce que
vous avez enfin prendre des mesures
concernant l'activité physique adaptée
qui est bien meilleur en termes de
prévention que bon nombre de médicaments
qui coûtent très cher donc j'aimerais
bien qu'on évoque ce sujet là merci
merci madame la Présidente moi je
souhaitais revenir sur la télé
consultation nous sortons d'une
discussion sur la difficulté d'accès aux
soins et sur les pistes que peuvent être
donnés bonne piste de la
téléconsultation et je voulais vous
faire part d'une expérience du
fleurissement de cabine de consultation
entre dans les supermarchés entre les
sous-vêtements les valises et les
produits d'entretien des supermarchés
qui vendent ce je cite la santé au
quotidien donc comment entendez-vous
encadrer ces pratiques qui ne me semble
pas vertueuse au moment où on manque de
médecins je suis pas sûr que les
médecins derrière ces plateformes
apportent une réponse aux besoins de
soins de nos de nos concitoyens et je
m'interroge sur ces dérives merci très
bien je vous laisse répondre
[Musique]
comme je l'ai évoqué le dès lors que le
sujet de la carte Vitale biométrique à
l'objet d'une notre travail de
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales nous y contribuerons bien
volontiers
peut-être simplement partager avec vous
mais mais même si vous le savez bien que
la carte Vitale aujourd'hui elle
bénéficie quand même d'un certain nombre
d'éléments de sécurité
il y a une puce qui porte un certain
nombre d'éléments qui permettent de
vérifier que que c'est bien vous il y a
une photo on a une seule carte Vitale
venant changer pas quand vous changez de
régime quand vous quand vous n'avez plus
droit à l'assurance maladie parce que
vous quittez le territoire nous mettons
la carte sur la liste d'opposition il y
a tout un procédure qui fait que ça
n'est pas une simple carte que que l'on
brandit comme ça et qui permet d'être
remboursé donc je cette carte Vitale
elle a fait l'objet depuis
une dizaine d'années de mesure de
sécurisation il n'y a pas de carte
vitale sur numéraire
qui circule sur le territoire il n'y en
a pas
très bien mais voilà mais voilà donc
après
si il y a des cartes vitales s'il y a à
un travail à mener sur la carte Vitale
biométrique nous y contribuerons
vous m'avez interrogé sur les actes
redondantes
[Musique]
nous
nous sommes extrêmement mobilisés sur
nos programmes d'action en matière de
bon usage du médicament de bon usage de
transport de bon usage des prescriptions
d'arrêt de travail de bonnes
utilisations des ressources du système
de santé nous avons notamment déployé
des actions autour de la lutte contre le
anti-burésistance de la promotion des
médicaments biochiminés bioséminaires
ce que je le disais de parcours de soins
qui sont plus efficients il y a dans un
projet boîte financement un sous-jacent
à Londres qui porte des économies à
hauteur de 700 millions d'euros sur ces
sujets là et donc il faut l'objet d'un
ensemble de plan d'action que nous
déployons sur les différents volets et
figure de façon détaillée dans le
rapport annuel chargé produit du mois de
juillet
vous m'interrogez sur le le l'espace
numérique de santé le DMP
nous avons terminé la phase la première
phase de déploiement de mon Espace Santé
puisque
conformément au cadre
qui a été voté par le Parlement nous
avons engagé au printemps le mécanisme
dit de l'optout c'est à dire que tous
les assurés se sont vus proposés
d'ouvrir leur espace santé et à défaut
d'opposition l'Espace Santé créé et donc
nous en sommes là je pense que dans les
prochaines semaines le ministre aura
l'occasion de faire un point plus
détaillé sur la montée en charge de mon
Espace Santé et les prochaines échéances
nous travaillons notre côté à
l'ouverture prochaine du catalogue
d'applications qui sera
plugué pardon de son anglicisme à mon
Espace Santé et puis à l'ouverture de
l'agenda de santé mais la première phase
technique opérationnelle a été réussie
et nous avons maintenant
près de 65 millions d'assurés qui ont un
espace santé numérique ouvert
madame la ministre m'interrogeait sur
sur le lien entre la
résume un peu le lien entre la
téléconsultation et la
prescriptions
notamment de d'antidépresseurs les
psychotropes pour être pour être clair
nous n'avons pas à ce stade mené de
travaux approfondis pour faire ce lien
mais vous vous l'avez vous vous la
mettez je vous en remercie entre
guillemets nous nous sommes capables
puisque nous disposons des éléments
d'information donc on peut tout à fait
mener ces travaux pour les porter à
votre connaissance et à celle de la de
la commission
nous nous constatons mais vous l'avez
vos capteurs en effet sont sont bons et
nous ils sont confirmés par les chiffres
une augmentation très forte des
prescriptions de psychotropes et y
compris chez les jeunes
sur les années on va dire covid que nous
avons d'ailleurs relayé là encore pardon
d'en faire la publicité dans le dans par
rapport annuel avec des chiffres
d'augmentation supérieure à 10%
donc il faut regarder précisément parce
que c'est toujours pareil il vaut mieux
vraiment poser les faits
je partage néanmoins avec vous que
et que aujourd'hui je pense c'est
toujours important de se dire la
téléconsultation ça reste un recours
quantitativement très limité c'est 3%
des consultations de médecine libérales
2% de spécialistes 4% des généralistes
donc je je je pardon je pense qu'il faut
être prudent pour relier ce phénomène
qui est quand même limité à c'est vrai
pour le coup une dynamique
quantitativement très supérieure et qui
concerne beaucoup de patients
d'augmentation de psychotropes après
ça rejoint quand même entre guillemets
et là aussi des discussions que nous
avons nous aussi avec des professionnels
de terrain sur le bon usage de la
téléconsultation et quelque part comment
dirais-je parfois un certain nombre de
de remarques que nous font les
professionnels de terrain qui nous
disent on a beaucoup travaillé sur la
qualité des prescriptions on a monté des
groupes de pairs on a on a une démarche
territoriale avec voilà des médecins
généralistes spécialistes et on voit
parfois des téléconsultations de nos
patients qui arrivent avec des
ordonnances on sait pas d'où ça vient
c'est une téléconsultation avec assez
lourdes en termes de prescription et
donc des questionnements donc il s'agit
pas de jeter nos propres encore une fois
sur cette pratique on en a besoin ça
s'installe dans la durée on va regarder
plus précisément pour répondre à votre
demande essayez est-ce que quand on voit
une téléconsultation quand on relie à la
fois d'ailleurs une perception de
médicaments et sans doute pas de
consultation avant ou après c'est des
choses qu'on peut regarder aussi
qu'est-ce que ça dit du suivi mais
honnêtement c'est quand même ça ça me
semble sans doute délicat d'imputer une
part importante de cette de cette
augmentation à la place de la
téléconciation mais encore une fois on
va vous on va mener ce travail
dans le détail
sur l'activité physique adaptée
alors
je rejoins bien volonté sur le fait que
notamment les travaux scientifiques
vont
dans le même sens c'est-à-dire pour
montrer un intérêt de l'activité
physique adaptée pour la prise en charge
après il faut regarder comment et quand
se pose quand même une question
délicate mais je la pose quand même
est-ce que pour promouvoir l'activité
physique adaptée il faut forcément un
remboursement de l'Assurance Maladie
est-ce que l'assurance maladie doit tout
rembourser je dis pas non je dis juste
un débat que je me permets de porter
auprès de la Fondation nationale
nous sommes prêts à éprendre notre part
mais faut-il
un faut-il systématiquement penser à un
remboursement je pose la question
nos partenaires organismes
complémentaires sont aussi partis
prenantes d'expérience et et pour vous
répondre plus précisément nous avons
engagé un certain nombre de de travaux
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle
l'article 51 c'est à dire les
dispositifs expérimentaux prévus par la
loi de financement pour 2017 qui
justement prévoit là pour le coup une
prise en charge de l'Assurance Maladie
sur des dispositifs d'activités
physiques adaptés donc à un certain
nombre d'expérience sur les territoires
qui sont en train de se mettre en place
et sur lequel
je pense que nous pourrons
l'année prochaine
partager un certain nombre d'éléments
d'évaluation pour voilà contribuer au
débat sur cette prise en charge en tous
les cas nous sommes de notre côté
extrêmement favorable à ce que les
différents leviers permettant à la fois
de développer l'activité l'activité
physique au sens large
et l'activité physique adaptée dans les
cas qui justifient nous sommes
favorables à soutenir ces différentes
ces différents dispositifs
la téléconsultation et les télégamines
en supermarché
je vous rejoins bien volonté sur le fait
que je ne suis pas absolument sûr que
que le supermarché soit la bonne place
pour faire pour faire une
téléconsultation
voilà
après il appartient pas à l'Assurance
Maladie de de réguler
le réguler cette chose là on en a pas
les pouvoirs
comme je le disais il nous semble à la
fois que un statut des offreurs de
téléconsultation
un dialogue territorial aussi et un
investissement territorial avec avec les
professionnels de santé sur la
téléconstitution j'étais hier soir dans
les Yvelines en discussion avec les
médecins porteurs du sas des Yvelines
qui sont en train de construire des
systèmes de plateformes territoriales de
téléconsultation qui permettent à la
fois de mobiliser de la téléconsultation
et aussi dans des conditions qui de
proximité qui garantissent une
connaissance du territoire une
connaissance des médecins traitants et
donc ça me semble être quelque chose à
promouvoir
et en tous les cas nous aurons ces
discussions là aussi avec les médecins
dans le cadre de la convention médicale
donc
encore une fois je le redis une
assurance maladie est favorable
au développement de la téléconsultation
mais qui s'inscrivent dans un parcours
de soins qui s'inscrivent dans un cahier
des charges de qualité de transparence
de qualité des prescriptions et je pense
de ce point de vue là que l'article de
la loi de financement nous permettra de
progresser dans ce sens
Nadia solo prenez pas le Savary année
chaque main et
merci madame la Présidente alors
Monsieur le Directeur j'ai quatre
questions vous avez évoqué les dépenses
covid donc un milliard d'euros sur
vaccin test je voudrais savoir si les la
prise en charge des patients atteints de
covidon et pris en charge sur une autre
enveloppe ou si c'est devenu totalement
en dessous du viseur voilà ce que
c'est une population quand même dont il
faut tenir compte parce que elle est
exponentielle ou pas après vous avez
parlé d'aide à l'installation j'aurais
m'assuré qu'il s'agit bien d'aide à la
primo installation parce que on voit
dans nos territoires des phénomènes de
désinstallation et pour rassurer les
élus peut-être qu'il faudrait valoriser
la stabilité des soignants plutôt que de
valoriser leur déplacement
oui enfin des patients sans médecin
traitant quand vous parlez de parcours
de soins et j'ai peur que le
déremboursements en fin des arrêts non
pris en charge des arrêts maladie en
téléconsultation on a quand même moi je
suis élu dans la Nièvre il y a beaucoup
de qui n'ont pas de médecin traitant qui
ne peuvent pas être dans un parcours de
soins matériellement et bien à leur
corps défendant
et enfin concernant la population des
kinés des infirmières vous aviez dit que
la dynamique était franchement positive
puisqu'on en forme de plus en plus de
façon claire mais peut-être que il nous
serait plus pertinent d'avoir le solde
entre ceux qui entrent et ceux qui
sortent parce qu'il y en a aussi de plus
en plus qui arrête voilà merci beaucoup
très bien alors René Paul Savary oui
trois points
des précisions par rapport à la question
de Philippe mouiller en ce qui concerne
les cartes vitales et vous dites qu'elle
ne circule pas or on voit directement
sur Internet les possibilités d'en
acheter on peut vous donner les prix
d'ailleurs et en conséquence est-ce que
est-ce que ces cartes là est-ce que
c'est carte là vous avez la possibilité
les maîtriser ou pas
deuxième question pour être un peu plus
précis par rapport à votre réponse par
rapport à aux conventionnement des des
médecins la question qui a posé
corinaire sur la conventionnement
sélectif est-ce que dans cette nouvelle
négociation vous introduisez le
convention le conventionnement sélectif
pour les médecins font des sur des
critères pouvant tenir à la densité
médicale
ce qui serait tout à fait nouveau me
semble-t-il et troisième question
j'ai sous les yeux une feuille de
remboursement de frais d'optique
par la mutuelle enfin une caisse le
général d'optique en complément du
remboursement du régime obligatoire
d'accord régime obligatoire il remborne
il rembourse sur la monture
0,03 € sur les verres
0,03 euros par verre ça tombe bien il
voulait une paire de lunettes c'était
pas un monocle il sera un peu mieux
remboursé il n'empêche que est-ce que
vous pensez pas qu'il serait temps quand
même de d'essayer de clarifier les
choses quoi c'est pas possible vous
ferez d'instruction ils sont beaucoup
plus chers que les remboursements qui
sont accordés on reste sur le principe
que la complémentaire effectivement
vient dans les frais optiques en
complément de faudrait peut-être que on
travaille ensemble sur des pistes
différentes d'un régime supplémentaire
et qui fasse en sorte que nos
concitoyens puis comprendre tout ça
parce que ça les révolte de voir ça quoi
merci
Jacques même
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur j'avais deux questions à vous
poser puisque celles sur les actes
redondants a déjà été posé
concernant les aides techniques dans le
département du Doubs et peut-être
ailleurs s'est mis en place une filière
de récupération et de recyclage des
techniques qui sont donc vendus
d'occasion et on a vu et on sait tous
que notamment les fauteuils sont des du
matériel qui coûte cher qu'en est-il
d'un éventuel remboursement par la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie ou
au moins une participation sur ce
matériel d'occasion est-ce que vous avez
mené une réflexion par rapport à ça et
la deuxième question que j'ai à vous
poser émane en fait j'ai été contactée
par les laboratoires d'analyses
biologiques
demandée par
qui on parle dans l'article le 27 du
PLFSS de considérablement réduire
le prix de leurs actes donc ils sont un
peu inquiets par rapport à ça tout en
ayant en étant conscient que pendant la
période covid ils ont fait énormément de
tests et donc qui ont été largement
financés
voilà il préférerait rembourser une
partie de cette somme et que leurs actes
de biologique de base ne soit pas autant
impacté que ce qui est prévu voilà merci
pour votre réponse et pour terminer
Laurence Cohen
oui mais merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur bon j'ai une
question à vous poser parce que il y en
a beaucoup qui ont déjà été posées c'est
le mérite de passer en dernier
des syndicats des noms me semble-t-il
juste titre Monsieur le Directeur une
proposition de transfert de charge de
150 millions de l'Assurance Maladie vers
les complémentaires santé et d'ailleurs
quand je dis 150 millions si on pense en
année pleine c'est 300 millions vous
savez mon attachement et l'attachement
de mon groupe le groupe communiste à la
sécurité sociale et on a même déposé une
proposition de loi avec des financements
je suis ici Monsieur le Directeur à
votre gauche non
c'est pas c'est pas hasard
à gauche toutes et donc vous savez notre
attachement à la sécurité sociale et
d'ailleurs on a déposé une proposition
de loi sur le 100% sécu avec financement
etc donc je trouve que ce
transfert de charge et très dangereux et
même si je ne partageais pas du tout la
les positions du ministre Véran comme je
ne partage pas la politique du
gouvernement Macron que ce soit l'ancien
ou le nouveau je trouve que c'est quand
même un petit une petite modification
concernant les complémentaires santé
qu'il n'avait qu'il n'avait pas été
effectué auparavant donc j'aimerais
avoir votre votre analyse sur la
question je vous remercie d'avance
très bien Monsieur le Directeur
oui
[Musique]
madame la fenêtrice sur le groupe le
alors sur le
l'enveloppe prévisionnel de dépenses sur
le sur le covid ne concerne vraiment que
le que les vaccins les tests les prises
en charge des copies de long elles sont
entre guillemets noyées voilà dans les
prises en charge normal ne font l'objet
je dirais pas de régulation et très
honnêtement font l'objet d'un suivi
limité si éventuellement le covid long
aboutit à une déclaration en ALD parce
que les conditions sont réunies alors
nous pourrons l'identifier plus
précisément mais derrière le covidon il
y a en réalité vous savez des des
pathologies de d'intensité et de contenu
très très différentes et qui rendent les
choses
difficiles à suivre
pour l'assurance maladie mais en tous
les cas aucun obstacle à la prise en
charge de ce covidon et je le redis
d'ailleurs aussi aucun changement et
aucun obstacle à la prise en charge des
tests et des vaccinations tout au long
de l'année 2023 quand même l'enveloppe
de 1 milliard d'euros serait
éventuellement dépassé on continuera à
prendre en charge des tests des vaccins
il s'agit évidemment pas de d'une
enveloppe fermée sur sur les les aides à
l'installation
[Musique]
alors ça fait partie des sujets sur
lequel on rediscutera avec avec les
médecins puisque il peut y avoir des
situations dans lequel des aides sont
affectées à des installations qui ne
sont pas des des primo-installation ça
peut être une deuxième ou une troisième
installation dispositif a été construit
comme ça il peut quelque part aussi se
concevoir quelque part de favoriser mais
je comprends les bas de favoriser des
installations dans des zones très
soudances par rapport à des zones très
surdenses si je si je prenais cet
exemple là on pourrait imaginer mais ça
fera l'objet d'un point d'État
que que nous allons faire avec les
médecins dans le cadre de la négociation
pour voir si comment nous faisons
évoluer ces dispositifs
sur la sur la télé consultation les
arrêts de travail
on est évidemment extrêmement attentif à
[Musique]
maintenir l'accès aux soins et à
maintenir l'accès aux arrêts de travail
pour les les assureurs lorsque j'ai
justifié et y compris bien sûr dans les
déserts médicaux je partage tout de même
avec vous que sur l'année 2021
il y a eu 13 millions de prescriptions
dans un travail 13 millions 600
000 seulement
concernent des téléconsultations donc ça
reste comme pour on se le disait pour la
constellation un phénomène extrêmement
marginal et seulement 110000 concernés
par ce dispositif c'est-à-dire 110 000
téléconsultation
prescrites par un médecin qui n'est pas
le médecin traitant
et nous avons regardé très finement les
choses et maintenant à l'exposition de
la commission des affaires sociales les
chiffres détaillés
le taux de recours à la téléconsultation
en zone soudance n'est pas supérieure à
ce qui se passe dans les zones à densité
normale il est quasiment identique on
est à 3,7 versus 3,2 % on est vraiment
voilà donc la réalité aujourd'hui c'est
que la téléconsultation n'est pas
un recours
à un problème de densité médicale et
j'aurais presque envie de vous dire
mettons nous en 2019
avant la téléconsultation
je crois qu'il y avait voilà ici il peut
y avoir un problème bien sûr des zones
en tension médicale les assurés
bénéficier de la un travail sans
téléconsultation
je rappelle que la mesure portée par le
gouvernement qui est il y a une
proposition d'assurance maladie c'est
vrai elle ne change rien à l'accès aux
arrêts de travail en présentiel vous
pouvez aller voir votre médecin traitant
c'est très bien mais vous pouvez aller
voir n'importe quel médecin n'importe
quel on s'entend tout médecin plutôt ce
serait mieux dit
qu'il pourra vous prescrire un arrêt de
travail si votre état est justifié en
ville à l'hôpital médico-social dans un
centre de santé donc voilà et je
repartage le chiffre 13 millions de
prescriptions d'arrêt de travail dans
notre pays
je crois que ça traduit le fait que on
doit y être attentif mais
comment dirais-je bénéficier d'un arrêt
de travail lorsque ces médicaments
justifié je crois que dans notre pays ça
reste un exercice qui n'est pas trop
compliqué on pourrait laisser le sens de
la mobilisation de l'assurance maladie
se dire que lorsque nous contrôlons un
travail et que nous obtenons des taux en
moyenne de 15 à 20% d'arrêt de travail
injustifié je pense qu'on pourrait se
dire que le problème est au moins autant
voire plus sur la justification que sur
les difficultés de recours aux arrêts de
travail mais c'est voilà parce que vous
m'avez compris
sur le solde des installations des
infirmières libérales et des et des et
des masters kinésithérapeutes alors je
vous donnerai pas le chiffre à la
centaine près en tout cas il est
peut-être
imprécis mais lors de grandeur est tout
à fait juste
on a un peu plus de 5
une augmentation de 5000 infirmières
infirmiers ou infirmière par an en
libéral en net en net c'est du sol parce
que je rappelle qu'on forme 30 000
infirmières par an dans notre pays 30
000 donc c'est un effort considérable
voilà donc 5000 en net et s'agissant des
Master qui étaient malades mais ma
soeurs kinés à 3700
en net dernière donc là aussi une vraie
dynamique en net
d'installation ce qui est positif
puisque ce sont des professions dont
nous avons évidemment besoin
ce sénateur ça varie de la carte vitale
[Musique]
dès lors que nous identifions et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
d'ailleurs demandé et obtenu avec les
autres caisses d'ailleurs de ce que les
social des pouvoirs en matière de cyber
enquête dès lors que nous identifions
une un trafic de carte vitale ou en tout
cas une proposition de vente alors nous
pourrons aujourd'hui nous pourrons
demain avec cet article agir puisque
aujourd'hui nous devons passer par
des officiers de police judiciaire enfin
tout un procédé un processus assez lourd
et donc nous pourrons nous mobiliser et
dès lors que nous identifions ce type de
trafic nous pourrons y mettre fin je
redis aussi à nouveau que chaque année
en tout cas
sur la dernière année nous avons réalisé
1,6 millions de contrôles sur la réalité
des droits à l'assurance maladie 1,6
millions de contrôles donc ce sujet
parle de carte vitale mais en réalité le
sujet c'est est-ce que les gens qui se
soignent ont effectivement des droits à
l'assurance maladie nous
de contrôle c'est une charge extrêmement
lourde pour les caisses au-delà des on
parlait des échanges de données des
transferts de fichiers qui permettent de
vérifier que la personne travaille bien
en France avec nos amis des Urssaf avec
nos amis émissaires à l'intérieur pour
vérifier la régularité du séjour etc une
fois que nous avons mené à bien ces ces
échanges automatiques de fichiers nous
réalisons 1,6 millions de contrôles
individuels notifiant nos notifs 300 000
fermeture de droits sur cette base là
parce que ce sont c'est 1,6 millions
ciblé puisque tout le reste on l'a
vérifié de manière automatique donc
c'est normal que sur ce ciblage on est
des fermetures de bras puisque c'est des
gens pour lequel nos systèmes
automatiques d'information ne détecte
pas de droit mais je le redis je les dis
publiquement il y a encore 15 jours le
montant financier des consommations de
soins liées à ces fermetures de droits
et limiter notre estimation c'est de
l'ordre de 70 millions d'euros
70 millions d'euros là où les
évaluations que nous menons sur d'autres
types de fraudes nous montrent des
enjeux financiers bien supérieurs donc
voilà maintenant la bonne utilisation de
la Carte Vitale la vérification des
droits à l'assurance maladie c'est des
choses qui font partie de notre plan de
lutte contre la fraude avec la même
intensité que nous avons sur les assurés
sur les prochaines de santé et sur les
entreprises qui fraude éventuellement ça
arrive des fausses des fausses
entreprises des choses à un travail ça
arrive également et nous devons être
vigilants sur l'ensemble du spectre
sur le conventionne en sélectif je je
suis pas sûr que j'ajouterai beaucoup de
choses à ce que j'ai déjà évoqué je
crois que le contexte de tension globale
sur la ressource doit nous amener à
réfléchir de façon
approfondie sur de telles mécanismes
pour un
point 2 je crois que la ministre le
ministre l'a rappelé ou la ministre
également d'ailleurs leur attachement à
une responsabilité collective une
mobilisation territoriale et pour
essayer de trouver des solutions nous
redisons aussi notre conviction je redis
ma conviction que
aider les médecins traitants
gagner du temps médical leur financer en
grande partie des assistants médicaux
aider à la coopération à d'autres
chaînes de santé ça marche on gagne du
temps médical et je sais que ce chiffre
est mal reçu parfois par nos amis
médecins mais quand je dis qu'en moyenne
un médecin prend en charge à peu près
1000 patients comme médecin traitant
l'expérience assistante médicale montre
que ça marche on y gagne il peut prendre
en charge plus de patience sans
travailler plus ça se dit pas travailler
plus vas-y travailler dans des
conditions différentes et que si demain
on arrive à faire monter cette moyenne
c'est quantitatif mais le défi il est
aussi quantitatif
et bien si on passe à 1200 on aura non
pas répondu au problème des arts
médicaux c'est sûr mais apporter des
réponses significatives aux gens qui
n'ont pas de matières traitant je dis au
passage alors je me permets de le dire
que dans les 6 millions de personnes qui
n'ont pas de médecin traitant il y en a
la moitié qui en a jamais eu
et qui n'en cherchent pas
et qui n'a peut-être pas besoin donc par
contre le sujet des 600 000 patients en
ALD qui n'ont pas de médecin traitant
c'est évidemment un sujet très important
sur sur l'optique peut-être juste qu'on
se pardon de le dire comme ça mais ce
que vous avez là est tout à fait normal
tout à fait normal pourquoi parce que
dans le cadre de la réforme du 100%
santé nous avons construit un système
avec les professionnels de santé et avec
les organismes complémentaires qui
prévoit que l'assurance maladie
concentre ses remboursements sur le
panier a
voilà donc on a on est sorti du
remboursement sur les tarifs qui ne sont
pas maîtrisés l'assurance voilà parce
que l'assurance m'a dit considère que le
panier a suffit pour proposer aux
assurés des montures et des verres de
qualité
et donc il est pas justifié que
l'assurance maladie met de l'argent sur
des montures ou des vers pour lequel on
est sur des tarifs différents la seule
raison de ce 1 centime dont je comprends
très bien monsieur sénateur ou trois qui
peut apparaître choquant ou compliqué
c'est un simple sujet de traçabilité
c'est un simple chiffre traçabilité si
nous n'avons pas ça si nous n'avons pas
ça nous ne serons plus rien sur ce qui
se passe sur ce qui n'est pas du pagnat
nous n'aurons aucune information puisque
puisque à ce stade les la mise à
disposition par les organismes
complémentaires des données de santé
n'est pas efficace et ne nous permet pas
d'appareiller les données de l'assurance
maladie obligatoire avec les données
complémentaires pour savoir ce qui se
passe en terme de prise en charge donc
si je passe si j'ai pas ce en fait ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon un code
traceur et ça arrive souvent en
pharmacie etc voilà après je comprends
tout à fait que voilà mais les
professionnels les professionnels ils
ont très bien compris non mais donc et
donc et donc comme dans le cahier des
charges du 100% santé ils sont en charge
mais mais ils ont une obligation
d'explication
ils ont une obligation d'explication
vis-à-vis du patient
oui
voilà donc voilà
mettre de l'argent de l'assurance
maladie sur ce type de prise en charge
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas de sens
donc voilà donc on a c'est simplement un
code traceur
Monsieur
Madame Jacques mes
il nous reste encore 5 minutes nous
avons
nous avons
nous avons échangé en effet avec un
certain nombre d'acteurs sur
sur les sujets de recyclage des
techniques on sait notamment avec avec
nos amis de
d'APF France handicap des démarches sur
lequel ils s'engagent dans des filières
de recyclage je il faudra que je vous je
revienne vers vous pour savoir les
conditions dans lequel on peut prendre
en charge ou pas c'est des choses mais
c'est des choses qu'on sur lequel on
travaille avec le ministère de la Santé
et avec eux pour voir si c'est en effet
des y compris en termes de sobriété de
bons usages des choses intéressantes
donc sans doute à approfondir sur les
laboratoires de biologie médicale
[Musique]
d'abord
je pense qu'il est très important de
rappeler que ce qui est proposé dans la
loi de financement c'est une négociation
donc ça n'est pas une décision
unilatérale c'est une négociation que
nous avons engagé puisque nous avons eu
beaucoup de contacts avec les
biologistes médicaux depuis plusieurs
semaines et nous avons formellement
engagé les discussions ce lundi
pour essayer de leur proposer un nouveau
cadre plus rien annuel
nous sommes extrêmement attentifs au
maintien d'un maillage territorial de
laboratoire de biologie extrêmement
attentif à la situation des petits
laboratoires comme comme voilà et le
maintien de leur activité
c'est le sens de ces discussions nous
pensons néanmoins que au vu de la
rentabilité du secteur quel que soit la
taille des laboratoires
il est possible d'engager des baisses de
tarifs
dans la durée de manière partagée avec
la profession avec des garanties qu'on
doit leur donner et c'est le sens des
discussions que nous avons engagées avec
eux
cette semaine
oui madame la sénatrice madame Cohen sur
le transfert de charge
alors c'est
le gouvernement en effet indiqué que
dans sa construction de la dame il avait
retenu un transfert de de dépenses vers
les organismes complémentaires de 150
millions d'euros ce qui n'est pas une
dépense ce qui n'est pas une un montant
anodin mais mais ce qui reste quand même
d'une portée limitée vous avez vous
connaissez bien le phénomène à l'oeuvre
depuis maintenant pas mal d'années de
concentration de la dépense de santé et
d'augmentation des pathologies
chroniques qui fait que le taux de prise
en charge de l'Assurance Maladie
Obligatoire continue de progresser
et notamment parlé du médicament c'est
extrêmement fort sur une des dépenses
comme
merci à vous